der eine geht der andere kommt
vielleicht wieder und beide galten zu
ihren besten Zeiten als ein Herz und
eine Seele als politisches Gespann
werden Boys Johnson und Donald Trump
wollen nicht mehr auftreten welchen Weg
jetzt das Vereinigte Königreich
einschlägt ist ungewiss das gilt ebenso
für die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
die auch um ihre Einheit bangen und
unter anderem wegen Donald Trump der
möglicherweise einen neuen Anlauf ins
Präsidentenamt nimmt
wankende Weltmacht USA kommt Trump
zurück jetzt in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Katrin klüberesch Volk ist bei uns
Politik deutsch-amerikanische
Politikwissenschaftlerin Jürgen Coburg
war
ehemaliger oder ist ehemaliger
Botschafter in den Vereinigten Staaten
und sie waren auch lange Jahre
Staatssekretär im Auswärtigen Amt Markus
Keim ist bei uns
Politikwissenschaftler bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und ralfreund
ist Vizepräsident von Republicans
broadgermany also der
Auslandsorganisation der
republikanischen Partei der USA hier in
Deutschland ja er hat es doch getan hat
losgelassen wo es nichts mehr
festzuhalten gab Boris Johnson premier
Boris Johnson ist Geschichte hier seine
abschiedsbotschaft
der Wille der konservativen Partei ist
deutlich dass es eine neue Führung geben
soll und damit einen neuen
Premierminister
und die Stimme überein dass dieser
Prozess jetzt beginnen sollte
ja was immer bei diesem Prozess dann
herauskommt bevor wir zum eigentlichen
Thema der Sendung kommen eben ein Blick
auf das Land dass ich mit den USA immer
besonders verbunden gefühlt hat und
gefühlt das ist das Vereinigte
Königreich von Großbritannien und
Nordirland Frau Krüger asbrook da geht
jetzt ein ebenso schillernder wie
unberechenbarer Politiker von Bord ist
das für Europa eine gute Nachricht mit
Boris Johnson gab's immer viel Ärger
besonders für die EU also wenn man den
europäischen Stimmen zugehört hat am
heutigen Nachmittag dann würde man
einheitlich sagen ja also Michelle
Barnier der ja viel verhandelt hat mit
der britischen Seite hat gesagt das ist
jetzt ein Neustart für die Gespräche
zwischen den Kontinent und der Insel ich
glaube auch ganz klar ist es ein
Neustart oder könnte es auch ein
Neustart für das amerikanisch britische
Verhältnis sein früher war natürlich
England das oder ein Großbritannien des
Tür die Tür zu Europa die Tür ist mit
ziemlich lautem Knall um den brexit
herum zugeschlagen stattdessen gab es
große Querelen mit dem Vereinigten
Königreich nicht nur natürlich um den
Erhalt des Statuts von Nordirland nicht
nur um die entsprechenden politischen
Protokolle sondern eben auch wirklich um
die populistische Politik eines Boris
Johnson die im besonders im
amerikanischen Kongress nicht besonders
hoch dotiert wurde jedenfalls auch von
den Demokraten also die Querelen die
waren wahr und richtig und das könnte
ein Neustart geben
ein Narr der alle anderen zum Narren
gehalten hat kein das Vereinigte
Königreich ist ja ein wichtiger Player
auf der internationalen Bühne kaum ein
Land von den USA vielleicht abgesehen
engagiert sich so auf Seiten der Ukraine
um den die russische Aggression
abzuwehren Boris johnson war ja schon
sehr früh in Kiew hat ja übrigens auch
dafür gesorgt dass das alle mitkriegen
bei seinem Spaziergang durch die Stadt
da ist er ja offensichtlich aus etwas
anderem Holz geschnitzt als Olaf Scholz
ist der besten denn jetzt etwas
geschwächt das ein solcher
doch mindestens entschlossen haben
Politiker verschwindet also eine
Vorbemerkung machen ich werde ihn
vermissen ich weiß das nicht die
Mehrheitsmeinung aber das schildernde
das Irrlichtern und das extravagante
auch das bunte das fehlt uns doch häufig
in der deutschen Politik und nicht aber
dafür steht ja auch wenn es nicht die
mehr als Meinung in der Beurteilung der
Person gewesen ist aber ich finde sie
machen eine ganz wichtigen Punkt ein
außenpolitisch ist der ist die
Sonderstellung Großbritannien ist etwas
ambivalent diese Vorstellung dass man
eine ganz unabhängige Rolle nach dem
brexit in der Welt entwickeln könnte das
hat sie so nicht bewahrheitet aber in
dem Fall den Sie angesprochen haben in
der Ukraine ist die britische Leistung
und die britische Führungskraft von
Brawl Stars sind schon bemerkenswert
aber kein Zweifel gelassen dass man sehr
frühzeitig sehr eindeutig ohne
Einschränkung die uränen Unterstützung
gerade auch wenn die Tiere so viele
andere Länder noch gezögert haben und
ich finde das wird ihm zu wenig
angerechnet diese Position
vom Parteivorsitzenden zurück und dann
im herbstwahrscheinlich als
Premierminister welche Konsequenzen
könnte das denn haben
bleibt das Vereinigte Königreich für
seine Verbündeten ein verlässlicher
Partner ist solange kein verlässlicher
Partner gewesen außer so keine angeht
und ich teile ihren Nostalgie nicht muss
ich ausdrücklich sagen denn was wir
brauchen sein stabiles berechenbares
England und das müssen wir endlich
wieder bekommen und ich fürchte dass die
Gefahr immer noch jetzt besteht dass
noch viel Unheil anrichten wird in St
antirurgischen Politik
nordirland-abkommen zum Beispiel das
Protokoll könnte wieder kippen seine
Mitstreiter alle wieder auch die neuen
wieder als in der alle brexitiert bis
auf die Knochen also ich sehe eine große
Gefahr und das hat wohl auch den
ehemaligen Kanzler super anders jetzt
mal zu überlegen was man macht um die
Verfahren abzukürzen er hat ja gesagt er
hat sich mit dem Bradley von diesem
1922 Komitee getroffen und der sei
einverstanden mit dem
mit dem Plan bis zum September oder bis
zum Herbst so warten die Zeit wird man
auch brauchen jetzt verfahren was ich
jetzt was jetzt beginnt dauert seine
Zeit und das wird man auch laufen lassen
müssen außer man schafft es jetzt dass
man die Sache wieder verändert durch
einen Beschluss am Montag Tagen ja Tag
der diskomitee wieder mit den neuen big
benchers mal sehen ob es etwas tut aber
die Gefahr dass hier nur etwas
irrational passiert halt für groß wenn
es nicht tatsächlich auf vor allen
Dingen auf das politische militärische
Bündnis im Namen des nordatlantikpaktes
das ist richtig das sehe ich auch so
aber ich muss auch sagen wir brauchen
ein Instagram ausgehendes verlässliches
England engination außerordentlich
wichtig als Partnerland gehört zu den
wichtigsten vielleicht und deswegen
hoffe ich nur dass der Nachfolger wer
immer sein mag dann auch neue Weichen
stellt der europäische Kontinent drei
Freund ist ja ein vielstimmiger Chor wie
sieht denn die USA auf den Zustand der
Regierungen und zwar sowohl im
Vereinigten Königreich als auch im
restlichen Europa also muss was dazu
ergänzen natürlich sind Trump und auch
Johnson absolut Individualisten und
deren Leistung steht natürlich da drin
ihre persönlichen nationalen Stärken
hervorzubringen sie sind überhaupt keine
Teamplayer das heißt also
die auch der Botschafter sagte so in den
Absprachen auch in den in den
multilateralen Verhandlungen haben die
nicht ihre Stärken sie haben ihre
Stärken eher in der Innenpolitik als in
der Außenpolitik aus muss man das ganz
ganz nüchtern sehen und so wird auch
glaube ich die Sicht der amerikanischen
Administration zurzeit gesehen die
Amerika die beiden Administrationen
möchten natürlich eine eine wenn man
sagen eine etwas verlässliche
Ansprechpartner haben ich glaube die
Drähte könnten jetzt sich nur noch
bessern
ja es gibt ja in Vereinigten Königreich
wie auch in den USA eine Besonderheit
nämlich eine Mehrheitswahlrecht das
immer dafür sorgt dass es kleine
politische Marschrichtung gibt
beide Länder sind ja auch berüchtigt für
die Polarisierung ihrer Gesellschaft und
hat das ein Zusammenhang
wir haben zumindest
von Demagogen wie einem Boris Johnson
und einem Donald Trump die Stimmung
machen können die verschiedene Wege
nutzen können um das Land noch tiefer zu
spalten die auch medial kooptieren
können so wie das natürlich besonders
der frühere US-Präsident gemacht hat die
andere Wege finden können mit Empathie
an Menschen heranzutreten die schwierige
Zeiten durchmachen das hat sowohl beim
brexit funktioniert wie auch bei der
Trump Kampagne aber wir sehen jetzt in
den USA wie sich das doch gegebenenfalls
etwas wandelt denn wir sehen eine
republikanische Partei die sehr mit sich
selbst hadert gerade wo der lagerkampf
zwischen den Trappisten und den
traditionellen Traditionalisten in der
republikanischen Partei aufbricht
vielleicht geht eben diese ganze Logik
nicht ganz so auf wie sich der frühere
Präsident das jetzt ausrechnet das
könnte sein dass die republikanische
Partei auch in eine Krise gerät wie die
Demokraten auch aber die republikanische
Partei in den USA hat eine vielleicht
nicht unerwartete Hilfestellung die die
Politik dieser Partei unterstützt obwohl
sie im Moment im Senat und im
Repräsentantenhaus in der Minderheit ist
nämlich das Oberste Gericht der Supreme
Court der jetzt einen Urteil nach dem
anderen abschießt das ja eigentlich eher
den ja fast den radikalen Teil der
Republikaner entspricht und das was
Trump da gesät hat mit drei einer
Richterin zwei Richtern diese Saat geht
jetzt auf ohne das Trump Präsident ist
verschiebt sich in den USA unabhängig
von Wahlen sowohl für den Kongress als
auch für die Präsidentschaft da gerade
etwas ja das hat sich schon erheblich
verschoben und ich möchte mal sagen dass
die Amerikaner und Engländer und sein
groß Geschenk haben gemacht haben nach
dem Krieg das war eine Verfassung der
mich Grundgesetz und ein Gerichtssystem
ein newcast System was eben diese
Weiterung nicht zulässt obwohl wir auch
schon diese Richtung manchmal tendieren
manchmal weiß ich Spaltung der
Gesellschaft angeht aber dennoch haben
wir doch sind wir gut gefahren mit nach
kriegsverfassung und wir können hoffen
nur dass bei uns auch gut geht aber sie
haben Recht die Spaltung Amerikas
gnadenlos geradezu ich habe sechseinhalb
Jahre dort als Botschaft verbracht habe
immer mehr gemerkt dass dieses Land mir
eigentlich fremder war als ich am Anfang
erwartet hatte wir haben ja im Prinzip
so eine Art Feuerstelle in den USA und
auf der einen Seite stehen die
Republikaner und ihre Anhänger und auf
der anderen Seite Demokraten die ja in
sich auch wieder gespalten und auch
uneinig sind und jeder hat ein Fass
Kerosin in der Hand und gibt es
ununterbrochen rein und auch die neuen
Richter zumindest die Mehrheit im
Supreme Court tut das auch
wohin driftet dieses Land da gerade ab
also Polarisierung gibt es überall aber
man hat so das Gefühl die Rasen mit
vollem Karacho auf die nächste Wand zu
und habe überhaupt kein Problem damit
dass es gleich knallt woran liegt das
oder ist das eine überzogene eine
überzogen und das betrunken ist ja dass
jedes Mal nach einem Wahlkampf oder nach
dem
bundeswahlkampfes alle Seiten Bekunden
bevorzugte Sieger jetzt sei die Zeit für
Heilung time for healing und alle wissen
dass es gar nicht passieren wird das gar
nicht darum geht und die Polarisierung
wird obgleich das kaum vorstellbar
scheint ja immer noch ein paar gerade
ein paar Umdrehungen weitergetrieben
wenn man sich das vorstellt im Moment
ist Meinungsbild zugunsten von Präsident
beiden dann ist ja bedrückend dass er
trotz der Tatsache dass der
amerikanische Kongress sich in der
Ukraine Politik weitgehend hinter ihm
versammelt hat sind seine Umfragewerte
in der Öffentlichkeit dafür von dieser
strös was gilt Umfragen von märz und vom
Mai die illustrieren das Republikaner
ihm schlechter bewirkt als Präsident
Putin das muss man sich mal
gegenwärtigen also sagen das ist das
Ansehen des eigenen amerikanischen
Präsidenten trotz der Tatsache trotz der
Tatsache dass man einzelne Waffen nie
vorher einzeln unterstützt der Hass die
Abteilung auf das andere gegnerische
Lager reicht so weit dass dieses übliche
Phänomen dieses dass man sich in
nationalen Krisen hinter dem Präsidenten
gesammelt vielleicht ein paar Tage
reicht aber zumindest nicht so tief
wirkt dass mir zu uns ins Präsidenten in
Gang kommt also da möchte ich jetzt
trotzdem was ergänzen also muss den
Zuschauern auch sagen dass die Spaltung
der amerikanischen Gesellschaft die
historischen Vergleich schon mal viel
größer war als im Zeiten des
Bürgerkrieges oder auch in Zeiten der
City right movement Ende der 60er Anfang
der 70er Jahre hatten wir noch eine
größere Spaltung also man sollte es auch
nicht überbewerten und auch die kommen
auch die hinweisen supremecard kann ich
nicht ganz teilen das ist jetzt nur
entschieden worden dass nicht mehr ein
Bundesgesetz gilt sondern das jetzt die
Bundesstaaten dort dort das Sagen haben
also es ist auch lieber der Todesstrafe
ist es ja auch auf Bundesstaaten Ebene
gelöst also das ist jetzt kein Argument
wo man sagen kann das führt zu einer
ganz diversen diversiven Gestaltung der
Gesellschaft
sich aber auch in einer grundsätzlichen
anderen Situation noch mal denn es geht
nach gerade der Wahl 2020 geht es hier
um die Beständigkeit der amerikanischen
Demokratie und das hat eben auch da bin
ich bei ihnen noch mal den Vergleich
auch zum zum Grundgesetz zu ziehen und
Standhaftigkeit von Demokratien
insgesamt das ist ja eine viel viel
größere Frage jetzt denn was wir gesehen
haben über die Jahre der
trump-administration ist das aus dem
Skelett der amerikanischen Demokratie
aus den Institutionen durch das ständige
angehen quasi das knochenmarktes
amerikanischen demokratischen Systems
des Raubbaus am demokratischen Körper
und das hat sich dann ja am 6 Januar
ganz ganz deutlich gezeigt diese
Verletzung im Inneren Herzen ich bleibe
bei diesem Körperbildern denn es ist
wirklich glaube ich auch für viele
Amerikaner und Herr Herr Dr Keim hat es
angesprochen ich glaube für zwei Drittel
der Republikaner glauben diese
verheerende Lüge weiterhin das ist
Pfusch grandiosen Fusch am
amerikanischen Wahlsystem gegeben hat
dass dann zu dem Aufstand am 6 Januar
hat führen müssen
Verteidigung der amerikanischen
Demokratie und wenn eine so große
Bruchstelle da ist im eigenen
Verständnis von Land Politik und System
dann ist es doch eine ganz andere Sorte
Krise als wir sie historische ergänzen
dazu also der Verlust das Vertrauens in
die amerikanische Institutionen ist ja
kein Phänomen sie haben das sehr gut
beschrieben was im 6 Januar passiert ist
aber das ist doch ein Prozesse seit 30
Jahren geht der Verlust in die Vertrauen
der Notenbank den Verlust Vertrauen in
den supremecard in das Gerichtswesen in
die Bildungspolitik und das geht
übrigens abseits der Parteigrenzen
möchte ich betonen ja bei beiden
Anhänger bei der Parteien auch
unabhängig vom Alter vom Geschlecht ist
der Verlust und das Vertrauen in die
amerikanische Institution ein Prozessor
seit Jahrzehnten geht und natürlich
wieder befeuert durch diese völlig bei
ihnen aber das ist doch jetzt nicht
etwas was auf einmal passiert ist das
ist etwas was seit langem gibt das muss
man jetzt auch nicht nur den
amerikanischen Präsidenten angreifen
die Europäer schlagen jeden Tag drei
Kreuze das sind der jetzigen Situation
Joe byten US-Präsident ist wie geht er
denn mit den vielfältigen Krisen gerade
um es gibt gerade eine internationale
Krise stützt ja normalerweise das
Ansehen des Präsidenten er hat im Moment
sehr viele Dinge an der Backe die es
auch hier in Deutschland gibt vom
Klimaschutz bis zur Inflationsbekämpfung
auch das ist in den USA ein
Riesenproblem wie
ja bewährt er sich gerade als
Krisenmanager oder ist da gibt es da
noch große Defizite bei Ihnen also
interessant finde ich das an der
Umfragewerte angefangen haben in den
Sturzflug überzugehen angesichts einer
anderen internationalen Krise das war
damals der Abzug aus Afghanistan im
August letzten Jahres dann wird gegangen
eigentlich so dass das Desaster in der
öffentlichen Meinung wenn man so immer
sagen darf und davon hat er sich nie
wieder erholt und es die öffentliche
Meinung gibt ihm auch keinen Vorschuss
trotz der Tatsache dass man sagen kann
mehr oder minder hat die Beine
Administration die gegenwärtige Krise
wäre russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
und die damit umzugehen sah eigentlich
mehr oder minder gut gemeldet denn
Umgang mit den Europäern der Eskalation
gegen Russland oder zumindest keine
direkte Konfrontation also da gibt es
eigentlich nicht viel zu melken aber er
bekommt nichts dafür und Dance Clans
genau die Dinge ins Kontroll die Sie
angesprochen haben Inflation hohe
Energiepreise bevor ich den Rezession
also all das was uns hier ja auch
umtreibt und das würde glaube ich auch
andere Präsidenten belasten da würde ich
jetzt gar nicht die Person Joe Biden und
die Parteizugehörigkeit im Mittelpunkt
stellen das würde auch einem Barack
Obama ins Kreuz gefahren sein die
gleiche Frage stellen die ich gerade in
Bezug auf das Vereinigte Königreich
gestellt habe
sind und bleiben die USA für uns ein
verlässlicher Partner ich meine das
militärisch politisch aber wir sind mit
ihnen ja auch wirtschaftlich verbunden
und eine krisenhafte Situation in USA
die könnte ja auch möglicherweise das
transatlantische Zusammenleben
beeinträchtigen zumindest hatten wir zu
Beginn als der Antrag diese Illusion und
die Hoffnung ich habe damals Artikel
geschrieben gesagt seit vorsichtig wenn
Herr Trump redet von American first
tretet beiden von Bayern American sehr
Tendenz etwas ähnlicher aber er war
verbindlich man konnte mit dem Reden
diese ganzen verbalen Juroren waren
weggefallen insofern war ein wunderbarer
Neuanfang für die Europäer
ist weitergeht und ich muss wieder sagen
die Spaltung in dem Land es geht so
wahnsinnig tief und die ganzen
konzentrationstheorien die dort
aufgelegt werden sieht der unerträglich
geradezu und das kann nicht zurückgeholt
werden sehr schnell aber wenn man nach
Deutschland blickt muss ich sagen auch
vieles die ganze Identität Bewegung bei
uns hat er ähnliche Züge natürlich nicht
also wir sitzen eigentlich alle im
selben Boot aber extrem ist es einfach
nicht gestartet aber die die Stellung
des Präsidenten in der US-Verfassung in
der in der Realität ist eigentlich ja an
die eines integrators für alle
Amerikaner da zu sein das hat er ja auch
bei seiner Rede nach der Vereidigung im
Januar 2021 so gesagt wahrscheinlich
haben die eher gemäßigten Republikaner
einen Schluckauf bekommen und alle
anderen
hämisch gelacht also gesagt ich bin der
Präsident aller Amerikaner geht da auch
ein Stück weit vom Amt des Präsidenten
etwas verloren als Integrator das
vielleicht auch über die Zeit der oder
die Amtszeit Joe Biden hinausgeht ich
würde das nicht als eine Veränderung
sehen das ist immer so gewesen der
amerikanische Präsident gibt sich immer
als als Präsident aller Amerikaner oder
Bundespräsident bei uns als
Bundespräsident der deutschen das halte
ich keinen kämpfen wir nicht sonderlich
wichtig aber er muss natürlich Stellung
nehmen wenn überhaupt glaubwürdig sein
will in bestimmten Bereichen die
betreffen natürlich besonders die
Republikaner und das macht ihn zu einem
parteisen Präsidenten der ist nicht
Präsident für aller Amerikaner kann auch
gar nicht sein ja schwierig ist aber
gerade in diesem Moment denn die
Demokraten fühlen sich gerade von ihm
sehr enttäuscht sie haben sich sehr
gewünscht gerade nach dem Gerichtsurteil
zur Abtreibung das ganz klar
amerikanische Frauen zur Bürger zweiter
Klasse macht jedenfalls auf der
nationalen Ebene und da hätten sich ganz
starke Gruppen innerhalb der
Demokratischen Partei einen vier
kämpferischen Joe Biden gewünscht und
weil wir eben in kürzester Zeit gesehen
haben dass das erste Mal in der
Geschichte der modernen Geschichte des
Supreme Court Rechte weggenommen werden
von Amerikaner anstatt dass das quasi
Rechte erweitert werden
der seit 90 Jahren nicht so konservativ
ist und sie auch nicht so tief in sich
das gesellschaftliche Leben der
Amerikaner einmischt und da haben sich
eben viele Demokraten umgekehrt
gewünscht von ihrem Präsidenten dass er
quasi als Fahrland zwischen der
Institution und der Bevölkerung machen
er ist ja er ist zwar verglichen jetzt
mit dem deutschen Bundespräsidenten
hatte ja sehr viel macht eine enorme
Macht sogar aber kann er wirklich so
sehr viel dagegen unternehmen was da
inhaltlich im supremecard passiert
erstes Mal hat er kann nur hoffen dass
dem Nichts mal Platz frei wird und einen
seiner
Freundin es gibt noch ein paar andere
Dinge das geht da natürlich geht es um
ganz grundsätzliche Fragen des Prozedere
da geht es ums philippuster da geht es
um viel Gesetze gemacht werden kann man
bestimmte Dinge über Gesetze absichern
und und und könnte man den supremecard
auch noch erweitern alles sehr
kontroverse Ideen aber im ersten Moment
hat er ja die Sprachgewalt er ist der
Präsident im besten Fall alle Amerikaner
und das ist eben das erstmal auch die
öffentliche Debatte anders zu fassen wir
haben vier gerichtshöf gesehen oder vier
Verfahren gesehen jetzt noch auf die das
fühlte sich sehr an als ob die auf der
auf die Schnelle durchgemalt werden zur
Erweiterung des der Waffen Nutzung in
den USA zur Infragestellung der
regulatorischen Kraft der der
Umweltbehörde dann die die ganzen Fragen
zu eben der der abtreibungsgesetzgebung
und dann natürlich auch noch Fragen zum
Wahlrecht und das wird in der nächsten
legislativen im nächsten legislativen
Moment oder in den nächsten Session des
Supreme Court genauso weitergehen dann
stehen dann große grundsätzliche Fragen
der amerikanischen Demokratie wieder auf
dem Tisch nämlich zum Beispiel das
summitive Action wie man ein Land
zusammenhält und auch quasi ja
gleichermacht und das ist ja der
pluralistische amerikanischen Traum Sie
diesen Aspekt man sagt ja es wird die
der Bundesebene wird Kompetenz entzogen
wenn ich das richtig sehe und es geht
auf die Bundesstaaten über also eine
sehr starke Föderalisierung politischer
Inhalte das könnte ja zur Folge haben
dass die USA mittelfristig regelrecht
zerfällt also eigentlich was zerfallen
sprechen kann wir haben ja auch
vielerlei Ebene nicht Strafe an die
Todesstrafe oder auch die waffenrechte
sind alle auf föderaler Ebene gelenkt
und Sie merken dann vom Sprung das
Verlust ins Vertrauen der Institutionen
aber ihnen anscheinend voll vorhanden
Verlust des Vertrauens und supremecalls
die machen eine Verbesserungsvorschläge
weil es ihnen nicht so gefällt aber ich
glaube das geht im Zuschauer viel zu
viel zu speziell ich muss also den
beiden fast ein Schutz nehmen ich meine
es im Ernst jetzt nicht zynisch der Mann
ist gewählt worden hat eben eine
rasiermesserscharfe Mehrheit in beiden
Häusern das Kongresses und ihr kriegt
seine eigenen wills seine eigenen
sitzvorlagen teilweise nicht durch oder
nur mit großen Aufwand und mit großen
Abstrichen und da wird er als
entscheidungsschwach wahrgenommen da tut
man ihm Unrecht meine Ansicht nach er
hat eine ganz klare Agenda er kriegt sie
aber parlamentarisch eben nicht durch
die Gremien durch und ich glaube das ist
kein Problem vom Präsident Weiden und
seiner und seine Agenda ist ein Problem
dass er eben die Wahl also Präsidenten
gewonnen hat aber eben nicht die Wahlen
so entscheidend
Balken wie er will und ich glaube das
ist die große Koks er ist auch sehr
politisch erfahren und wir werden jetzt
wir hören hier viel von
Widersprüchlichkeit innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei wir haben jetzt
die Zwischenwahlen vor uns und ich
glaube man darf sich politisch ja nie
reich rechnen Vorwahlen aber ich glaube
man muss kein Hellseher sein zu sagen
das wird nach allem was wir jetzt wissen
kann noch einiges passieren natürlich
dass die Zwischenwahlen möglicherweise
ganz anders ausgehen und eben nicht für
die Partei des Präsidenten zu seinen
Gunsten ausgehen werden die Sachen eher
schwierig schwieriger werden wird und
nicht leichter werden wird muss ein
Konsequenzen für uns alle in Europa
wir haben ja mit großen wir kommen auf
diesen Aspekt gleich noch mal zurück wer
mit großen Augen eigentlich zugeguckt an
einem Tag der Anarchie dem sechsten
Januar 2021 Sturm aufs Kapitol der
Versuch ein Wahlergebnis das längst klar
war noch mal zu verändern jetzt gibt es
da eine Untersuchungsausschuss im
Kongress
und es hat sich ja gezeigt dass es ja
geradezu eine kriminelle bis
verbrecherische Dimension dieses Tages
gibt
möglicherweise nach einer Aussage einer
früheren Mitarbeiterin Frau hatschzinsen
könnte es sein dass der Justizminister
Donald Trump sogar anklagt was wie sehen
Sie die Entwicklung daher km in diesem
bei diesem speziellen
Untersuchungsausschuss ist das für die
wird eine schwierige innenpolitische
Situation sein aber kann das in einer
Anklage gegen den Ex Präsidenten münden
ob das kann ich nicht beurteilen dafür
müsste man Verfassungsjuristen sagen was
ist hier justiziabel und ich bin auch so
ein bisschen vorsichtig die
demokratische narrativ zu glauben was
auf den ersten plausibel ist zu sagen
wir machen die die diese Anhörung die im
Moment in den amerikanischen Medien
regelmäßig übertragen werden die
bedrückende Befunde
vorbringe ich aber anders kann man das
gar nicht sagen bisschen die höchste
entscheidungsspitze hinein ein wenn das
mal in Anführungsstrichen kriminelles
Verhalten an den Tag legen aber ob das
tatsächlich auch in der amerikanischen
Öffentlichkeit Gewicht entfaltet da
würde ich doch Zweifel anmelden wollen
weil ich glaube mein Eindruck ist bei
vielen Leuten ist eher der Effekt ja wir
wissen schon was das was der Donald
Trump viel schlimmer Finger war also
sagen ob das für die zwischenwahl worauf
die Demokraten ihr Entsetzen das ist
wirklich das Zwinger hat an der Waage
ist sich so entwickeln sollte da bin ich
noch ein bisschen zurückhaltend warum ja
wenn ich dazu sagen darf es müssen
andere Dinge zusammenkommen wenn sich
den beiden mal ansehen
ich bin ja auch nicht gerade jung aber
dieser alte weiße Mann der über die
Teppiche Schleich dort löst drückt auch
kein Vertrauen mehr aus in seiner
Persönlichkeit er wird schwach an seiner
Art wie redet er wurde dieser Art wie
handelt wie er geht und mit diesem Mann
kann man keine Wahlen mehr gewinnen und
wenn die Demokraten nicht da eine Lösung
für nicht die Frau
die die
kommen natürlich nicht mehr in Betracht
aber ein dynamischen Mann oder Frau was
auch immer die irgendwo die jüngere
Klasse wieder bewegen kann die Hoffnung
erweckt in die Zukunft dann ist es
hoffnungs für ihn ein wichtiger Aspekt
komme ich gleich mal drauf zurück wenn
wir die Frage hat dann ob Donald Trump
möglicherweise noch mal antritt bei
Freund warum streuten die
republikanische Partei im Kongress
ständig Sand ins Getriebe bei den
Ermittlungen ein Teil ihrer Partei also
Mike Pens der damalige vizepräsident da
auch Lindsey Graham sind ja im letzten
Moment noch abgesprungen also gesehen
haben da findet ein verfassungsspruch
bis hin zu einem möglicherweise sogar zu
einem Staatsstreich statt warum arbeiten
sie da nicht oder warum arbeitet die
republikanische Parteien diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss eher nicht mit
sondern im Gegenteil blockiert wo es nur
geht es relativ einfach zu sagen weil
zur Zeit eben sehr viele champisten in
der Partei des sagen haben und auch dann
entscheidenden Stellen sitzen und das
eben
Traditionalisten ich sage eher Gio
Pisten dazu oder meinen die gleichen die
denen ich mich zähle also die Grand Out
Party und der unter den Republikanern
die von der regenbush Ärger geprägt
worden sind als ich damals in USA gelebt
habe mich den zugehörig fühle und dass
diese natürlich enorm bremsen und dort
vertuschen man kann das in Medien sehen
es ist eine ab 2021 Uhr ist es an für
sich eine richtige Medienschlacht die
einen sagen er hat falsch gehandelt aber
er hat wenigstens gehandelt ja sagen die
einen ja dann sagen das ist
verfassungsbrüchig das sehe ich ähnlich
und das schlimme ist eigentlich an
diesem sechsten Januar seinerzeit
gewesen nicht nur dass es Tote gab das
ist trag aber was wirklich bleibt ist
wieder dieser
Vertrauensverlust in die Institution
dass die Leute glauben dass die Wahl
manipuliert worden sind und da ist in
der Tat die wir jetzt auch sehen
tagtäglich gar nichts dran ja das war
eine das war eine ganz saubere Wahl aber
sie hat eben eine noch zu einer weiteren
Spalt und der Gesellschaft wenn ich das
Anfügen darf die Tage mal ausgezählt 200
Amtsträger also Mitglieder des
amerikanischen Senats bzw das
Repräsentantenhauses sie haben Teil ihr
sind als Teil ihrer politischen Agenda
explizit den Vorwurf die wahrsage
gestohlen worden also das ist eben kein
Phänomen mehr was nur in der Breite
irgendwo versickert was irgendwelche
völlig verrückten an den Rändern der
Gesellschaft
verbreiten Querdenker sozusagen dass wir
das deutsche erkennen sondern es ist in
den politischen Institutionen angekommen
und das ist ja das Bedenkliche und das
führt zu der Angst bei den vulkaner die
Verein zu verlieren das ist aber eine
doch durchlegt deswegen das beantwortet
jede ihr Fragen diese gestellt haben
nicht die Angst davor dass die Wahlen
verlieren sie müssen nur den richtigen
präsidenzkandidaten haben bei den
Demokraten und deswegen ist es glaube
ich wichtig nochmal darauf hinzuweisen
dass wirklich weiterhin Raubbau
getrieben wird an der amerikanischen
Demokratie über 400 Verfahren Laufenden
über 40 Bundesstaaten um das freie
geheime gerechte Wahlrecht
einzuschränken oder beschwerlich zu
machen wir haben wiederum über 40
Verfahren die in anderen oder in
verschiedenen Bundesstaaten laufen
gerade um sich anzuschauen inwieweit
oder nicht man in Wahlen eingreifen kann
es wird gerade hochpolitisiert wer zum
Beispiel die Wahlzettel auszählt und wir
erinnern uns sehr wir hatten gerade
Lindsay Gram im Gespräch er und
verschiedene andere republikanische
Kollegen sind gerade im Bundesstaat
Georgia vorgeladen worden
auszuzahlen weil wir in uns da wie
explizit auf Wahlmänner und Frauen das
Menschen die die Wahl kontrollieren
Druck ausgehen können
mit den Trump
seinen Hut in den Ring werfen auch um
möglicherweise eine Anklage durch den
Minister guter Punkt
ohne verfassungsrechtlerin zu sein das
ist der Punkt wenn Trump früh kandidiert
und früh seinen Hut in den Ring wirft
und den dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass
er unglaublich viel Geld gemacht hat mit
dieser Lüge 250 Millionen Dollar die er
verschiedenen Zwecken zugeführt hat um
damals um den sechsten Januar zu sagen
man könne diese Wahl retten mit diesem
Polster wird er sich seine Kampagne wird
er sie relativ früh starten und zwar im
besten Fall um aus der Schlinge des
Gesetzes zu entfliehen und das wird dann
spannend zu sehen wer dieses Rennen dann
mitmacht und da sind eben wiederum
gleich fragen aber mitmacht als Gio Pist
wie ich das jetzt gelernt habe also
grand old Party sozusagen die
Traditionalisten die die Grundwerte der
Partei hochhalten stehen denn dann alle
Republikaner hinter ihm wenn er diesen
Hut wirft nein ist natürlich eine ganz
ambivalen Veranstaltung ich frage es
auch wie ihr das taktisch macht ob er
jetzt dich von juristischen soll ich
sagen Motivation leiten lässt oder ob er
jetzt sagt ich warte mal die
zwischenwahl ab und schau mal wie so der
Wind weht
Tatsache wird sein wir werden
wahrscheinlich wird es besser laufen für
die Republikaner als bei den letzten
Wahlen möglicherweise sogar deutlich
besser danach wird er sich positionieren
spätestens dann und er hat den großen
Vorteil er ist bekannt das heißt alle
anderen müssen sich erst noch in der
Öffentlichkeit vorstellen er ist da und
wenn er gleich da ist kann er das
Medieninteresse auf sich ziehen man darf
nicht vergessen einfach nur historischer
Vergleich den bemühe ich immer so gerne
2016 da haben wir gedacht Hillary
Clinton wird haushoch nominiert
gegenüber Sanders zum Schluss hat die
Sender Stimmen gebraucht um überhaupt
eine Mini zu werden wir haben gedacht na
ich vor allen Dingen die selbst
ernannten Experten und Trump hat keine
Chance das wird Rubio das wird Cruise
das wird Bush zum Schluss hat er die
größte Mehrheit auf einem republication
Convention das eine Erstwahl seit
Eisenhauer seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
also da kann man sich furchtbar irren
bei so Dingen es
[Musik]
denn sie wissen genau was sie auf die
Zukunft die wissen ja sehr genau das ist
hoffnungsversuch mit ihm und
also ich glaube da habe ich es
Aussichten aber ich glaube und das muss
ich sagen gebliebener zu ihnen ich hoffe
dass die Justiz ja doch mal unermittelt
findet aber wir mit den Zeugen umgeht
wir die verunglimpft alle es ist ja
übelste Machart von der Trump wieder
nicht wir sehen ihn wirklich Editors
aber
es wäre historisch einzigartig also
mindestens seit jüngeren Geschichte das
sind amtierender Präsident sich nicht
der Wiederwahl stellt wir hatten das mal
bei Kater dass er schwer kämpfen musste
gegen Gary Harting gegen andere
überhaupt nominiert zu werden hat dann
hoch gegen Regen dann verloren aber das
ein Präsident das zweite Mal nicht mehr
antritt zur obwohl er lebt das hat
eigentlich seit der jüngeren Geschichte
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr
gegeben also es wäre einzigartig und ich
denke man darf eins nicht vergessen die
beiden ist vielleicht nicht der
Integrator für alle Amerikaner aber er
war beim letzten Mal die Integrator der
demokratischen ganz leicht also er war
diejenige der die Flügel
verletzt dich noch mal zusammenhalten
konnte
mit Konzession zu allen sein dass wir
die sozusagen nicht meine Sorge aber die
interessante Frage wenn man noch nicht
thematisiert haben werden ihm dann
folgen könnte welchen Weg die
Demokratische Partei dann einschlägt und
auch dass ihre Chancen eher erhöht oder
eher senkt und ich hätte eine Tendenz zu
fürchten dass sie ihre Chancen eher
senken wird wenn es nicht die
integrative Figur geben wird ja was
macht die Demokraten dann eigentlich in
dieser in dieser Konstellation
wird beiden dann wird vielleicht sagen
ich drehe nicht mehr an aber unterstützt
das die Partei dann in ein großes
Dilemma denn viele der Prominenten in
der Partei die nicht so Indikativ sind
wie Joe Biden die er nur in Long Island
und Long Beach sozusagen die Society
kennen und da ankommen aber in diesem
ganzen alles was dazwischen was so schön
fly over country heißt eher nicht in der
flyover Dynamik die einen sich zum sie
sich schon im letzten Wahlkampf einen
Namen gemacht haben und die jetzt
vielleicht schon mit den hufenscharren
da denkt man an den früheren
Bürgermeister von South Band Indiana man
denkt dann Piet bootet die Frage ist
aber genau wie Herr Dr kaltens eben
schon angesprochen hat ist Amerika jetzt
in dieser integrat ist das ist der
Kulturkampf jetzt so ausgetragen dass
man sich jetzt einen Schulen Präsidenten
in zwei Weiße Haus wählen kann denn was
wir gerade sehen ist das Abarbeiten an
den grundsätzlichen kulturellen
kämpfen in den USA wo immer die Idee war
Amerika Demokratie ist ein
immerwährendes Projekt der Pluralismus
setzt sich durch und es entwickelt sich
weiter und jetzt sind eben genau diese
Dinge werden jetzt grundsätzlich in
Frage gestellt also wird man schauen
müssen welcher welcher Kandidat und ich
würde mir wünschen für die Demokratische
Partei die strategisch denken muss was
sie nicht getan hat in der auch in der
Abtreibungsfrage sie hatten zwei Monate
Zeit quasi vorzubereiten mit welcher
Antwort sie in den Startlöchern liegen
denn wir hatten ja ein ein eine vorab
gerne wenn man so will der Gedanken der
obersten des Obersten Gerichtshofs das
haben sie nicht gemacht oder jedenfalls
nicht genug gemacht man würde sich jetzt
umgekehrt wünschen dass die
Demokratische Partei jetzt schon
strategisch viel nacharbeitet um genau
einen einen oder eine Kandidatin zu
identifizieren die sie dann vielleicht
auch spät noch mit einem historischen
Bruch ins Rennen schicken könnte also ja
aber die Demokratische Partei ich kann
nur für die replikaner sprechen aber
sein letztendlich wenn jetzt die
Zwischenwahlen kommen und sie gehen
jetzt tatsächlich wirklich schlecht aus
oder vielleicht sogar desaströs aus und
dann hat natürlich ein Riesenproblem
geht man dann mit einem angeschlagenen
Präsidenten in der Präsidentschaftswahl
oder holt man noch am letzten Metern
noch ein frisches Gesicht heraus wie
auch wieder den Zuschauern Mitte ein
bisschen historisch betrachtet bei der
ersten Wahl bei der ersten zwischenwahl
nach einer präsentschaftswahl gehen
normalerweise 23 bis 28 Sitze im
Kongress zu anderen professionellen
Partei das ist ganz normal
es hatten alle das hatte jeder nur
George Bush Junior Sondersituation mit
dem Irakkrieg da war es ein bisschen
anders aber sonst ist ganz normal aber
ein Mann wie Obama hat zum Beispiel ein
Rekord hingelegt mit fast doppelt so
viel mit fast 55 sitzen dir verloren hat
und warum obwohl er seine Wahlziele
erfüllt hat Irakkrieg beendet
Gesundheitsreform alles gemacht und
warum nicht weil die Erwartungshaltung
unglaublich hoch war und das ist der
Vorteil von beiden hat keine hohe
Erwartungshaltung beiden ist nicht
gewählt worden das Leidenschaft beiden
ist gewählt worden weil er zuverlässig
ist und weil er eben eine Anti Trump
Alternative angeboten hat die antitramp
Alter brauche aber nicht mehr Trump ist
nicht auf dem Stimmzettel jetzt bei der
zwischenwahl und das ist ein ein
Hauptgrund warum die Demokrat
möglicherweise ihre Wähler nicht
mobilisieren können das wird sehr
spannend sein
gut was spannend wird in den nächsten
Jahren sicherlich auch eine spannende
Frage auch die Frage ob eben Trump noch
mal die Wahlen gewinnen kann nicht nur
Boris Johnson hatte einen hohen
Unterhaltungswert das gilt ja
gleichermaßen für Donald Trump der
Antritt eines preis-boxers aber wenn das
passiert aber für die das den Europäern
wird wahrscheinlich das Lachen vergehen
über ihn wenn tatsächlich wenn er noch
mal gewinnen sollte wenn er nochmals
Weiße Haus einziehen sollte was heißt
was würde wir sind in der Abteilung was
wäre wenn was würde ein solcher Wahlsieg
für das transatlantische Verhältnis
bedeuten also wir sehen ja im Moment
aufgrund des ukrainekrieges also das
russischen Angriffs auf die Ukraine ja
eine hebliche Wiederbelebung
Wiederentdeckung der transzenden
Beziehungen der NATO die ist nicht mehr
gehirntot oder Hirntod die sie noch vor
zwei Jahren beschrieben worden ist ganz
im Gegenteil es gibt keinen passenden
Gegenbegriff aber wir wissen wovon
sprechen und ich würde auch sagen die
deutsche außensicherheitspolitik ist so
transatlantisch orientiert wie sie lange
nicht wahrgenommen habe oder wahrnehme
und dem die Kehrseite dafür ist da die
Kehrseite dazu ist dass alle Überlegung
der letzten Jahre die haben mit Trump
auf Trump zurückgehen europäischer
Autonomie strategische Souveränität eine
nicht Abkehr von den USA aber eine
größere Distanzierung die Frage welche
unabhängige Rolle könnte die USA spielen
die Europäer in der internationalen
Politik spielen doch erstmal von der
Tagesordnung genommen sind und ich
glaube wir würden dir Klavier Leben das
würde alles genau wiederkommen oder
veränderten Vorzeichen ist es dann
schlechter Coburg dass das von der
Tagesordnung gekommen ist müssen die
Europäer nicht vorbauen für die Zeit
nach 2024
wir werden es tun müssen vermutlich mal
und die Europäischen Union findet sich
ja zusammen im Augenblick und wir haben
natürlich so großes Problem mit
Frankreich im Raum das wäre der unserer
eigentlicher Verbündeter jetzt und haben
wir versagt auch in unserem Umgang mit
mit Frankreich wir haben nicht geholfen
dass er die Wahl doch noch mal gewinnt
also wir haben auch Fehler gemacht wir
haben sehr viel verstanden letzten Endes
bei uns das ist ein Problem aber wir
müssen einfach eine europäisches ein
Europäischen Union herstellen die jetzt
auch ihren Namen verdient und die
gemeinsam auftritt aber sie erweitert
sich zunehmend die zerflettert auch
zunehmend auch mental das natürlich
unser Problem und hier brauchen wir
Führungspersönlichkeiten ich hoffe dass
Herr Scholz ist einigermaßen kann er ist
einmal in der Eingriff eigentlich der
letzte Führer sogar noch der macron ist
außerordentlich geschwächt im Augenblick
trotzdem müssen wir wieder aufbauen wir
müssen hier eine Gemeinschaft finden und
deswegen ist der Fluss der Engländer
muss wieder sagen so besonders los für
uns denn diese pragmatisch zuverlässig
gewesen auch in ihrem Verhalten aber das
ist vorbei aber wir brauchen jetzt auch
die Italiener natürlich wieder diese
drei großen Länder müssen zusammen gehen
wie es der Vergangenheit mal der Fall
war diese wiederernährung könnte wieder
Makulatur werden der Honeymoon zwischen
USA und Europa der im Moment stattfindet
wieder verschwinden wenn Trump kommt
wird er denn wieder versuchen also nicht
jetzt unbewusst oder aus aus
Nachlässigkeit sondern ganz bewusst den
besten zu spalten
man kann sich das vorstellen wenn er
andere Antworten hat und ich glaube ganz
wichtig wird sein was für ein Personal
kann ein Donald Trump ins Weiße Haus
holen wir haben gesehen ein Arbeiten für
Donald Trump ist ein Karrierekiller und
zwar für die Leute selbst die die
Republik und die Demokratie retten
wollen da tut man sich keinen Gefallen
mit also es ist eben auch aus dieser
Dimension gefährlich wer würde diesen
Mann noch beraten und inwieweit würden
und mit welcher Ansicht würden sie ihn
beraten wichtig ist natürlich ganz klar
das Verhältnis zu China wie würde damit
umgegangen werden ich bin ganz bei
meinen Vorrednern dass Europa natürlich
jetzt ganz klar erstmal die eigenen
Interessen auch klar machen werden muss
das ist das heißt es ist umgehend
wichtig dass die Bundesregierung sich
reinlehnt in die Projekte die sie vorher
hat einen nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
gegebenenfalls ein Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat das ganz klar wird auch
was wofür Deutschland steht in der Welt
dass das was wir transatlantisch haben
welche vertiefen können wir denken an
den
eu-us-technologie und und handelsrat
alle diese müssen sitzen und passen
unsere wirtschaften müssen nahtlos
ineinander greifen dann kann er so viel
so schnell nicht anrichten aber dennoch
es wird darauf ankommen wie ein Donald
Trump in die Welt blickt wie geht er mit
China um brandgefährliche Situationen um
Taiwan herum und nochmal was ist die
Einstellung eines Donald Trumps zu
Russland und zu Putin
Trump besonders Charakter her eine Rache
durstiger Mann und der wird sein Müchen
kühlen an den Europäern er wird
Rechnungen begleichen wurden in erlaubt
dass sie im geschuldet werden also ich
fürchte dass ein Wiederkehr von Trump
große Probleme aufwirkt aufgrund der
Reaktion bei uns aber auf seiner
Rachsucht auf seiner Seite Angela Merkel
wird er da war ja nicht mehr antreffen
er hat sich ja immer als oder häufig als
politischer Hooligan gebärdet könnte es
denn sein wenn wir jetzt mal die
aktuelle Politik ansehen dass er sich
eine weitere Unterstützung im Ukraine
kriegt teuer bezahlen wird ganz so wie
in New Yorker Geschäftsmann der Weise
hat hier eine Monopolstellung euer kann
jeden Preis verlangen und gleichzeitig
aber mit seinem Kumpel Putin den er
offenbar auch ganz toll findet weiterhin
Geschäfte machen das kann eine ganz
fidele Angelegenheit werden durchaus
aber wir sind doppelten Konjunktiv er
muss erstmal nominiert werden beim
replikanern dann muss er die
präsentschaftswahl gewinnen und wenn er
deshalb wir reden ja die von diesem
Szenario
alles geschafft hat glaube ich an der
Außenpolitik hat ja auch dann gleich
gesagt als Putin losging wir können ja
gleich auch mal macht eine gute Sache er
verteidigt seine Grenzen und man sollte
vielleicht auch Mexiko ein paar Panzer
aufstellen also ich glaube mit so einer
Außenpolitik
werden wir nicht gut beraten also ich
glaube das könnte wie Sie sagten so
schön etwas verharmlosen die fidele
Veranstaltung werden aber
unwahrscheinlich ist es ja nicht wir
reden jetzt nicht von einem
Wolkenkuckucksheim also ich sage so
schlimm genug also ich glaube also wir
sind doppelten Konjunktiv ich glaube
Donald Trump ist dann eine ähnlichsten
Situation die beiden bei seiner Wahl er
ist dann auch geht auf die 80 zu wir
wollen das ganze mal beobachten lassen
Sie uns von Wahl zu Wahl schauen wir
haben Sie zwischen Wahlen die sind
entscheidend und danach sollten wir es
noch mal besprechen das interessante
finde ich man kann die Gleichung auch
ohne Trump machen
der amerikanische Außenminister hat eine
interessante Rede gehalten Ende Mai
wurde die zukünftigen Prioritäten der
USA skizziert hat und der hat deutlich
gemacht in dieser Rede dass diese
Hinwendung die wir im Moment zu Europa
gut finden die wir genießen die wir
hervorragend finden temporär sein wird
fertig gemacht das wird ein
Momentaufnahme sein und die wirkliche
Bedrohung trotz des Krieges trotz Putin
trotz der Ukraine wird in China bleiben
das heißt die strukturellen
Rahmenbedingungen die innenpolitischen
Zwänge deuten losgelöst von Trump nicht
in die Richtung der Europäer das müssen
uns klar sein schon die nächste
Besprechung hier angekündigt das wird
wahrscheinlich spätestens um die
Kongresswahlen im November stattfinden
wahrscheinlich vorher denn dann wird
möglicherweise auch Donald Trump Anlass
liefern dass wir eine neue
frühlingsrunde machen ich bedanke mich
bei Katrin döber aeschbrock bei Ralf
Freund bei Jürgen grobok und bei Markus
Keim liebe Zuschauer das war die letzte
Phoenix Runde die letzte reguläre
Phoenix Runde vor der Sommerpause die
erste reguläre Phoenix Runde nach der
Sommerpause die ist am 30 August bis
dahin gibt es ein Phoenix Sommerprogramm
dass wir für Sie vorbereitet haben mit
interessanten sehenswerten spektakulären
Dokumentationen und Reportagen schauen
Sie einfach rein jetzt folgt der König
der Tag mit Constanze abratski darin die
Rücktrittserklärung von Boris Johnson in
voller Länge bleiben Sie bei uns